yellow and things will come to do
playful no fan from the fan from the UK
a formula renters are oh okay he goes
for accepted ready gambit I've played
him a couple of times I'll be fine what
am i doing day I again I am sometimes
need a moment we should be 73 before now
is the rage the current trend to play
before here in this position the other
continuation taking on v3 is getting why
pretty good compensation so they play
default is taking a while we have
forgotten no you take yeah this is a
line where white always enjoys some
compensation for the pawn it's a tough
to save it is more than enough for just
enough for the porn but and always felt
that white is comfortable Black has
problems here with this development yeah
he was the C porn the bishop is on b7
and again he has lost time there with
the king which is tough to avoid really
you have to somehow react to the bishop
d 183 ok so what to do here just before
you drive and then 90 for the good
choice and think unless you have some
tactics on c5 stuff but I don't quite
believe that this should work we'll see
ok
two
we are alternative to 95 that would be
rather surprising if there was there is
an alternative to that why do you go
there interesting so yeah Knight wants
to go to f5 I guess ok I'll it4 looks
entirely normal I just wonder if there
is some kind of see fire but I don't
quite see it I think I can take I can
also put the night on to d6 that's also
an interesting square
yeah I'm fairly certain he will play c5
at some point too soon to get get the
bishop activated okay h3 and g-forces
kind of normal here but I don't quite
know he might play the c5 business I
think this time management is weird who
of what what else when I th six maybe
I'm just not getting things but okay
yeah you never know maybe it's like
enjoying his tea or something something
like that okay so g-form was kind of
mandatory here to prevent 95 mandatory a
strong but with close to that yes
absolutely I would like to like to
prevent c5 completely I have to move
Knight f6 in this position I don't know
this is doing much to be honest you
cannot take it twice
it is interesting I mean I feel like he
he won't take it any way that I also
attracted to this move let's play it
just putting more control over see fire
and covering the night we'll see Knight
to f6 I get what the AOS f9 to d6 as
well and now he goes back well I can't
play nice 25 now just play for that
playfulness bind unsure about it but I'm
going to do it
hmm that's interesting I have 95 now and
then plant the night on to the six okay
can also move the book bag I don't think
taking is doing all that much
interesting stuff ok I put this I played
like that for them to take basically
I've got a very strong compensation he
will probably play Queen 27 take 27
[Music]
maybe Queen to d8 going to seven air I
also have this and look to the 6 i'm
going to do that the loop on to d6 is
also looking quite good I that's not so
good I would have loved to go to afford
it's difficult to do now probably
94 tix f4 might even be possible it
looks pretty pretty bad from black add
it's tough time morning it's tough I'll
do it the night belongs on to you for I
mean yep so I'm I just don't care about
the material here flame for the attack
would have loved to have more time to
figure it out completely rigid decision
this must be right it says very little
doubt there now have seven is collapsing
no nothing special that he has here a
visually eight was the only move anyway
I thought I was the book was hanging
right what am I talking here and this is
probably this probably was stronger than
I initially thought looks like looks
pretty pretty busted maybe Queenie 6 was
better but taking taking a piece is it
would start
Quincy one and as a rezar of something
Quincy one no but it isn't up Tori chick
ok ok let's play it you want you can
take advantage Jack Scott of freedom
check on t5 now that will be enough talk
to win with this kind of time now that I
made my life difficult them after the
start with black work really completely
busted
[Music]
yeah you have to draw now I guess
objectively know there are offered I can
still try but ok I'm Jeff good I was
stupid to try it hey you scared more
time but he's pretty slow ok ok stop
yeah okay i'm sure i've taken this
lawyer but I don't think eight to take
draws in games where I am so I was aware
check I can take that checkmate we
should have taken the draw then I just
hate hate to take draws after and
playing such a dominating game yeah so
it was a completely one-sided game
actually really so yeah here White has
excellent compensation any played many
wacky me with 94 why not t5 is that a
bad square probably this one anyway so
after that like is pretty much done and
right what what the engine says 1.6 gym
what can i say i'm pretty happy with
what I did here ok 96 was even better I
read your spot for choice him it's such
a such a bad position yeah this is not
this is not as convincing as I see you I
mean pretty much over yeah this is not
harmful black either until the shipping
ya esta Copa she made of course ended
what I want to always set here
here why just just wins quite quite
clearly yeah queen is six I took too
long for that I can just take 36 or
whatever check okay okay yeah and yeah
it's technically speaking trachea f5
probably still might win but 19 seconds
is the thing okay I should take the
drawl a time and release I don't pay to
make jaws simply if you if you have such
a one-sided game before but of course
actually is what i should do right when
it is there a bit you're just not i know
it's all in my DNA in this kind of
situation to make a draw I still want to
win somehow because I feel well staff to
how the game went why should win and
knock like one even getting the draw
that it's not very practical understand
a suit cannot help it anyway thanks for
watching